[Music]
so what happens if you get a little too
close to a mountain lion
well a hiker in utah is describing a
terrifying encounter near his home
he recorded this on his cell phone which
is not exactly what i think i would do
in that moment but
26 year old kyle burgess met the animal
on a trail south of salt lake city
it is graphic evidence of what happens
when humans get too close to the wild
creatures
carter evans has more on their very
scary meeting
no get the way this is the moment kyle
burgess comes across a mountain lion and
its cubs
while on a trail near his home in utah
saturday
go away please go in holy
the roughly six minute encounter began
as burgess was about two miles from the
trail head
it was when i got down coming down slate
canyon
is where i ran into the kitty cat
that kitty cat was accompanied by an
adult mountain lion
seen running toward burgess that's when
he says he knew he was in trouble
get the way you see the two cubs and one
kind of runs off
but yeah uh rafter then i didn't notice
mama's right there and that's when i
knew it was a
not a good situation to be in the
mountain lion follows burgess who slowly
backs away while attempting to
intimidate the animal with loud noises
it then lunges hisses and flashes its
teeth
several times no
burgess says he had no idea what to do
it was all improv like i'm not
no outdoor expert at all kate remsin who
works for the living with lions project
says that while encounters like this are
unbelievably rare
burgess actually did many of the right
things you want to make yourself look
big
you want to be as loud as possible and
then like he did
slowly begin to back away remnant says
the mountain lion wasn't stalking
burgess but rather
trying to push him away from her cubs
these mountain lions are not going to
actively attack a human being
unless they need to defend themselves or
they're scared
the encounter ends after burgess throws
a rock and startles the animal who then
runs away
after realizing he's safe at last
burgess could barely hold back his
relief
it was just like it's over like those
six
minutes were so long for me for cbs this
morning
i'm carter evans it's only funny because
he survived yeah
and the way that he did it too i think i
would need the adult diapers at that
point and the fact that he could
just have the presence of mind to still
keep filming
i don't know how he could do that i'd be
concentrating on i'm getting rid of the
mountain lion not not my
my video yeah this is a generational
divide i think i i i also would not be
filming
that rock way earlier i think kyle
you've got a nice souvenir at the moment
but the alternative could be that
kyle burgess you go but the thing is he
he came into the
the cubs first and so she was just a
mama protecting her little baby exactly
so we get that but we're glad that he
lived to tell them i like what he said
in the video i like what he said he's no
outdoor expert he was walking on a road
i think he needs to work on his roar a
little bit though i like the grunts the
loud noise